votre vie vous échappe
demander une mesure d'éloignement
devient normal
aller s'installer dans une autre ville
normale mais vous continuez à voir votre
harceleur partout je sais que c'est mon
imagination
mais je ne me sens jamais en sécurité
j'ai d'autres formulaires à vous faire
remplir retirer vos vêtements
mettez-vous en sous vêtements la porte
est verrouillée se redresse mieux que
vous fassiez ce que je vous le demande
il ya forcément eu une erreur
enseignants ça vous avez donné votre
accord pour un internement volontaire on
veut retient ici contre mon gré vous
savez combien d'appels de ce genre les
flics ont chaque semaine mais ces
défauts qui les appellent cet homme qui
m'a suivi jusqu'ici harceleur il est si
la banque personne de croire je vais te
dire sortir on peut rien faire tant
qu'on n'a pas la preuve qu'un délit a
été commis
je dois être simple et qui s je dois
être
on a découvert un cadavre je dois être
il est ici peut-être que tout est dans
la tête
[Musique]